[Music]
you
56 seconds of logos and three of them
are Sony companies that Sony has to
remind you or Sony by putting their Sony
on it movie opens with almost a minute
of action that happens toward the end of
the movie because why would we want any
of the stories future events to be a
mystery that's no fun it's why I include
spoilers in every sins video also
incredibly convenient for the story that
this guy gets to live in a house in a
completely abandoned neighborhood were
not even homeless people dare to trip
that already money is particularly
dickish to the guy disabling the alarm
that if not disabled will cause them to
get arrested the director said let's
have your character eating an apple at
the very beginning of the movie it'll
make us all look more like assholes also
who does that the students in the middle
of a heist and is like need my nutrition
while I'm working
money's Bergling skills are on par with
Marv and Harry from home alone peeing or
masturbating after seeing the fluid that
hit the floor I'm gonna say pee but this
dude really enjoys peeing doesn't he
also a great job leaving your DNA all
over the foyer of this house asshole
all right you did it you successfully
robbed these rich people now it's time
to relax in their house this trio of
bandits have robbed several houses
together but this is the first time
they've collectively discussed their
plans to run away unless Alex's dad is
also their janitor on top of being their
security system provider there is no
reason for him to have a key to all his
clients homes
old windows screensaver is expositional
enough to be a screen saver while
leaving the desktop image of Alex and
his dad visible for the viewer to see
18:37 Bonavista street houses with your
dad's security company already checked
so one of the robber kids is the son of
a guy who works for the security company
so if these people keep knocking over
houses that use the same security
company don't the detectives start
thinking about employees or family of
those employees as the prime suspects is
this place they're in a restaurant where
they obviously ordered some food but
it's abandoned enough to talk openly
about the house robberies houses with
your dad's security company I already
checked not only does this insane blind
man have a security monitoring system in
this dilapidated neighborhood instead of
just bars on his windows and a load of
guns but it so happens to be a security
system installed and monitored by Alex's
dad's company which is impossibly
convenient content aids major larceny
unless he's referring to an official in
the US military then I have no idea what
major larceny is he may mean grand
larceny but there's no way to know that
amount makes a serious cop presence I'll
do an investigation but all the other
robberies you guys have done they've
been like wow these guys stole less than
$10,000 worth of stuff so we won't need
to investigate that too hard and by the
way isn't it weird these robberies keep
coming up just short of $10,000 every
let's go catch some people speeding if
we do this right we never have to do it
again but you have no way of knowing how
to do it right because you don't know if
he even has this money in his house at
all the whole plan to commit gret I mean
major larceny is built on a hunch that
this man is the kind of weirdo that just
keeps very large sums of money in his
basement or between his mattress and box
spring or in a safe behind a busted
piece of drywall I mean they'll be right
but still is there some sort of blurry
focus sunset going over this phone also
text message plays the pronoun game to
set up the next scene that requires
little to no setup apparently if you
google someone's address it won't just
show you their house on Google Maps it
will also bring up articles about court
cases the homeowner was involved in
google has certainly gotten creepier
over the years I mean Google is
fantastic and YouTube is the greatest
media outlet in history also sure let's
type in the exact address of the place
you're about to rob directly into a
search engine no one will ever make a
connection to you the security company
and the place you're robbing the story
is brought to you by Zoltan Berta the
Detroit News finance editor because if
it involves money at all this guy is
your man even if it's a settlement in a
fatal car crash case and if you read the
first couple of words of this article
you will realize mr. Zoltan has never
written an article before orgy of
evidence that this family is broken
watching cops numerous large empty beer
bottles on the table chimney smoking
this guy has swastika tattoos it's
almost insulting there isn't a crack
pipe or a body outline lying on the
floor somewhere
Alex reads up on the army vet who lost
his daughter and got a settlement from
it and it's basically the gangs
conscience but he reads this guy's story
and now he's like he probably kidnapped
and artificially inseminated the girl
who killed his daughter in a creepy
basement so let's Rob it also our kids
these days just texting each other and
all caps now or are they just all caps
texting because they're trying to match
the blunt and aggressive tone of the
movies first ten minutes also why does
she have this phone set to military time
hey you know Mubi tries to make Rock
East evening into something good so that
she can get her sister out of this house
but stealing an army veteran's dead
daughter settlement jeez maybe this
broken home isn't broken enough to make
that okay also Rocky's little sister
wants to be a surfer because she's also
been watching this movie and knows that
rocky wants to move to California so she
says this to give Rocky the perfect
setup to say which he apparently already
knows of course this guy lives in a
desolate ghost town neighborhood where
he's the only one left
somehow this neighborhood didn't get
turned into a Walmart as any news has
here yeah I was compelled to get it
because I knew you'd asked me about it
forcing me to explain more of my
backstory
also that tattoo looks pretty good for
just getting it yesterday no swelling
and only slight
in prison she got so fed up with the
crying that she would lock me in the
trunk of her car but there was this um
little hole in the trunk and one time a
ladybug flew and kept me company made me
feel safe I'm not one to judge someone's
got thrown in a trunk experience but
that sounds like bullshit to me
the lighting alone would prevent you
from even seeing the ladybug much less
get comforted by it
my name is just outside and was unable
to see the Rottweiler coming at them he
was also quite enough until he got to
the window to be a jump-scare dick Sir
Guy you mean the guy you said was a
shut-in and hasn't left the house in
five days according to your surveillance
video how do you miss him leaving the
house that's kind of doctor I'm a blind
guy isn't it not if he's a military hero
and lost his daughter in a car crash
it's not lets her out let's be asleep or
he's Bluffs playing damn it beat me to
it you mean you guys have been casing
this place for five days and you don't
know that he uses four locks on his
front door when he gives backup keys at
the security company because no one
gives keys to their security company
movie keeps making me sin this general
direction as the master keypad he'll
kill the alarm how was this not
discussed before you guys left
yeah but why this guy has four locks on
his front door some of which he doesn't
trust the security company with puts
bars at his window has a bolt on the
cellar door but he's not savvy enough to
put bars on one of the windows in his
house hell he put a motion sensor here
so he knew there was a chance someone
might try this
including a security company he doesn't
trust apparently the blind guy decided
to set an alarm on basically silent so
that it wouldn't wake him up if his
sensor is armed then opening that window
would immediately sound the alarm not
quietly ask you to enter the code she
must have got it by now she's fine
yeah well I say this right now does
money seem like the type of guy who
won't do something stupid if you insult
him in the middle of a robbery they all
decide to take their shoes off inside
potentially leaving behind evidence that
all three of them were in the house
so is this really the plan they're just
gonna snoop around the house and hope
they stumble upon a large sum of money
that isn't under lock and key inside the
house just so you know this hammer will
be useful later in the movie here it is
up close so you can remember which
hammer it is grieving father watches or
in this case listens to home videos of
his kids cliche and here's a Rick Grimes
gun completing the tour of weapons that
will be important later time money
assumes the knockout gas worked within
five seconds of him applying it these
kids try to pry the door open this way
instead of just trying to pry the lock
off the door or just go into the little
tool area next to the kitchen grab a
screwdriver and just unscrew the lock
from the door and doorframe
damn dude shut the hell up stop trying
to make it sound like you're the good
burglar y'all really think just cuz you
jerk off to her Instagram selfies that
makes you were Romeo how did you find
out about that oh he's talking to Alex
carry on what are you blind he's clearly
been deaf up until now based on how much
noise you guys made getting into this
house without him waking up I kind of
find it hard to believe that the blind
guy doesn't hear Alex's footsteps at any
time during this close call in the
hallway or his attempt to get out of the
way or smell him I noticed a change in
the atmosphere Arcata feeling in his
trick knee he seems to only be
perceptive when it plays into the
story's plot everybody just happens to
be in the place they need to be to
figure out how to steal the money also
considering the paranoia this guy
displays and how he sensed there was
more than one robber here seems like
he'd be a little more cautious about the
safe the manufacturers of this safe are
out of business now I can't remember why
blind guy is actually keeping thousands
of dollars in a safe inside his house I
guess after he won his settlement the
judge handed him a briefcase filled with
money which I assume is how it works in
Detroit who's calling this asshole at
3:00 a.m. right now and since winter
phone buzzes that loud not charging your
phone before a heist blind guy can't
smell the actual people standing right
in front of him but he can smell their
shoes the blind man has this girl tied
up in the basement complete with a
string that rings a bell to tell him
she's moving but why did the fluorescent
lights turn on and off too is it for the
jump scare he also allows her to keep an
expositional newspaper next to her in a
little padded area maybe just as a
reminder for the terrible thing she did
but more so she can show passers-by who
she is when the blind man was designing
his home he opted for the dim and
ominous red lights that don't really
provide any practical lighting this safe
which has up to eight numbers you can
fill in has the exact same code as the
money safe and why does he have another
safe down here for the keys when he
could simply have those in the same safe
upstairs well when I finally released my
kidnap victim I want to make sure the
keys are down here already better get
another safe for convenience these girls
don't immediately start running away
from the guy with the gun
staying exposed and the only small
opening he has for shooting purposes
convenient abandoned neighborhood
continues to be convenient maybe you
should've thought about this before you
started shooting up the cellar you knew
this girl was up because you heard the
bell ring so why did you shoot so
indiscriminately you've been to war man
you know better perfect chance to walk
slowly the out of here waste it
I can tell just by looking and I
memorize the way the locks look on the
front door I think it was okay with
these guys finding ways to be super
silent when the blind man was around but
now I'm floored they survive this
running around in the dark basement
filled with an obstacle course seen
stupidly saying things out loud ex ma
c'mon what are you waiting for
you have another kidnap girl who killed
your daughter down here do you guns
empty but still a sit
how the fuck do you know that you're
still in the dark just got strangled how
the hell do you know where you are
why first off didn't the blind guy turn
off the breakers second off if he only
turned off the breakers for the basement
why did he do that instead of the whole
house third off even if he didn't why is
there light up here the last time I saw
this area all it had was a red light
which should be off anyway and no light
behind the door so you're telling me
this blind man turned on the light
before he went to the cellar door to
start shooting people Todd how did the
dog get in here did the blind guy leave
the doors open for the dog to get in I'm
almost sure he didn't since the doors
are still up and I don't think this guy
has a doggie door considering all the
security he has in place and the blind
man was in such a panic to kill these
fools I doubt he woke up his dog
Unchained him and put him in the house
just in case dude did you forget what
you guys found out before entering the
house rocky had to go through the one
window that wasn't block remember
totally and completely astonishing he
didn't bring this gun in the first place
when he first thought there might be
intruders in this house
the blind man no longer has the blood
stains on his shirt that were there when
they were in the cellar I guess he found
the time to change shirts when he was
down there are you sure about that
yeah blind dude kidnap and kill the
woman but you still broke into his house
and tried to steal almost a million
dollars once again Vince that are big
enough for an adult to crawl through to
make John McClane proud
Alec survives this to an insane degree
where he's only unconscious for a few
minutes and has no scars or death
afterwards also the dog was able to push
Alex through this window and he wasn't
immediately stopped by metal bars why
did he and rocky think they were trapped
in this room when they could have
escaped through this window Alec
survives even more this as I see Alex
survive every fall crash choking and
head smashing in this movie I wonder why
Charles Xavier never recruited this gift
even though the blind man killed the
power when they were in the cellar the
washing machine can come on because it's
on battery backup you understand nothing
faint Cindy took my child away from me I
thought they told me fair she gave me a
new one and he is yet another whammy for
the movie introducing us to the
wonderful world of this guy artificially
inseminating his kidnapped victims to
get a new child believe me this makes
the movie way better when you find out
Papa dragons basement full of jets also
this movie officially turns the villain
hero thing on its head to justify all
the actions we've seen in this movie
these kids who rob people's houses are
now forgiven because this guy is even
worse than they are
Luffy fails to show Alex's backup power
supply and computer screen POV that he
obviously has built inside him from his
time at Skynet
so movie expects me to believe that the
blind man was able to beat the shit out
of Alex like he wasn't blind but when he
goes to kill him he completely misses
and stabs money's body even though the
blind guy was standing right over Alex
dawn finds its way out of the HVAC and
the wall I guess because this is
actually a video game dog that whenever
it gets stuck gets to restart from the
spot there's no God I don't know have
you met Alex this is exactly what I
think it is not a rapist I never forced
myself on her your honor all I did was
artificially inseminate her while
keeping her against her will so despite
the fact that I'm going to jail forever
or at least I have my morals just this
all of this why is there hair in it
don't answer that
holding the turkey baster in this way
allowing man seed to drip out also this
is not a contest I don't think you need
that much or do you now I'm doubting my
personal man seed production only now
it's almost completely full what was he
doing for that one second considering
what we know of Alex this is literally
deus ex machina just in case the homo
semen thing wasn't as distasteful as it
could be we will now stab him with the
baster and make it joke on it the blind
man decided to take the bag full of
money down to the basement with him
after taking it off of rocky and leaving
it in another room in a previous scene
because he understood a movie is being
made and needed to keep the money
conflict going
first off even if the blind man was able
to get out of the basement he would have
had to run to the room where the gun was
and if you recall he didn't know where
that gun was after he threw Alex into
the workbench because he proceeded to
use hedge clippers second off I can't
believe they're saying alex is dead here
after all the other stuff he survived
even after being bludgeoned with a metal
hammer assaulted by a jizz baster and
handcuffed to a padded room this old
blind man was able to rush up behind
them and shoot Alex before they leave
the house will you just leave the
premises please haven't you had enough
they tired and beaten Rocky's still
manages to outrun this dog Rocky has an
amazing magical bag that disappears at
random times so no one else can steal it
if it's filled with money not only does
rocky have a magical disappearing bag
she also has magical regenerative pants
that can sew themselves back together
after getting cut during the attempted
insemination this is clever but I feel
like taking her sister to California and
getting a waitressing job is easier than
the bull she's going through just to
keep the money dog continues to go after
her face instead of biting literally
anywhere else you can go now you can go
now how many get away fake outz if we
had in the last five minutes I count
five Ruby shows me the moment it showed
me at the beginning of the movie making
me feel like I just wasted the last hour
and 20 minutes of my life oh you you and
your face of course the remote to turn
on the alarm is here because of course
it is of course blind guy doesn't know
how to properly disarm his own security
system if the siren goes off rocky this
tremendous trouble leaving a situation
when she has the chance
the cops come quickly to a house in the
middle of a neighborhood no one knew
still existed and they somehow don't see
rocky running after turning this corner
News playing in the background that's
important to the story cliche this
visually impaired man was able to defend
himself shooting and killing both his
attackers on the spot detectives were
baffled and all the Jews and the obvious
kidnapping dungeon in his basement but
what a man does with his jizz and a
turkey baster and an obvious kidnapping
dungeon in his own house is his business
stable condition death is a stable
condition right because she's definitely
killed it movies so aggressively wants
to sequel it allows this blind man to
survive all this this is puppet dragon
my name is Lester Burnham this is my
neighborhood subliminal liminal and
super you understand nothing you know
nothing
all that is black gold I have been
stabbed shot poisoned frozen hauled
electrocuted and burned
[Music]